-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
That's so good to hear.
Let's get to the news.
Vice President Kamala Harris
met virtually today
with the president of Guatemala.
Incidentally, Guatemala
is what Fox News insists
her first name is.
It was announced on Friday
that President Biden
will visit Atlanta
later this week,
despite Georgia's
new voting laws,
which, for some reason,
forbid it.
The FBI arrested a man last week
who allegedly participated
in the January attack
on the Capitol,
after he bragged to a matc
on the dating app Bumble
and she turned him in
to authorities.
Is she still single?
Yes.
But did she find something
better than sex?
Also yes.
[ Laughter ]
Advocates for D.C. statehood
protested last week
outside of Senator Joe Manchin's
houseboat.
Because, after all,
if a boat can be a house,
then D.C. can be a state.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
the White House has recently
been working to rebrand
Second Gentleman Doug Emhoff
as Douglas,
in order to emphasize
his more serious side.
Oh, come on.
You can be serious
and go by a nickname.
Do you think this is
the fun version of Bernard
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in New Hampshire
are currently
investigating a family,
after they admitted
to using more
than 80 pounds of explosives
during a gender reveal party
So, I don't know if the baby
is a little boy,
but the husband certainly is
Former Olympian and reality TV
star Caitlyn Jenner announce
on Friday she will run
for governor of California
and has reportedly been advise
by former President Trump'
campaign manager, Brad Parscale.
Said Parscale, "I'll do my best,
but I can't guarantee
you'll lose by 7 million votes."
[ Laughter ]
According to a recent survey
29% of people -- 29% --
excuse me -- of people
think there should be emoj
that clearly portray sex.
Not to brag, but,
for some of us, uh,
there already is.
[ Laughter ]
Because it means something
[ Laughing ]
It was announced yesterday -
Shoemaker's is just like
a cloud of smoke
'cause he's gone!
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughing ]
Rocket ship.
It was announced yesterday
that fully vaccinated American
will be allowed to travel
to countries
in the European Union
this summer,
which is bad news
for unvaccinated Americans
and terrible news for Europeans.
The Orlando Sentinel published
an op-ed Friday
by a man who claimed he ca
no longer enjoy Disney World
because it's too woke.
The man's name?
Walt Disney.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, customs official
in Texas recently seized mor
[ Laughing ]
than $4 million
of methamphetamine hidden
inside a truck carrying pickles.
Your Vlasic bait-and-switch.
[ Laughter ]
Goldich.
It's a risk,
putting the punch line
like two words before.
[ Laughter ]
I'm sure he worked
on ending with it Vlasic,
but couldn't figure it out
[ As Johnny Carson ]
Your Vlasic bait-and-switch.
[ Laughter ]
You guys, that was a monologue